hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft für euch jetzt erstmal
so ja wir gucken jetzt die folgen blabla
alles gechillt und so für mich ist
allerdings meine tastatur ist kaputt
also an die zahl 12 47 und neuen
funktionen funktionieren noch nicht so
sachen wie ein schrägstrich oder so das
heißt wenn ich irgendwelche kommerz
eingeben muss ich immer ein
schreckliches im internet kopieren
einfügen und alles mögliche also ich
muss mir daran eine neue tastatur kaufen
gehen dann hab ich gleichen termin in
köln und meine softbox geneigt sich auch
langsam dem ende zu und geht mehr oder
weniger glaube ich jeden moment kaputt
es ist gerade alles nicht so cool aber
ich habe mir gedacht ich nehm trotzdem
minecraft folge auf übrigens wenn
irgendwie meinen bauch knoten heute ich
hab auch extrem hunger aber egal wir
fangen direkt an mit dem ersten vers war
wo der zugesendet
ich weiß nicht wie lange bist du ein
junge oder ein mädchen bei dem namen bin
ich mir da nicht so sicher tut mir leid
das ist jetzt keine beleidigung aber ich
habe den namen einfach noch nie gehört
oder ela oder ella entweder er oder ich
weiß es nicht aber jedenfalls hat er mir
geschrieben mach doch mal ändern wasser
wir kennen uns alle
der fordert sich direkt weg weil er
angst vor wasser hat allerdings die
ender milbe das ist ja dieses neue
kleine teil das hat keine angst vor
wasser das körper dar einsetzen und die
die lieben wasser die spielemesse ich
alles sie bekommen auf jeden fall kein
schaden und die ender melden sind ja
eigentlich so schächter beziehungsweise
so kleine kinder von denen am ende die
tauchen ja oder spawnen manchmal wenn
man einen ändern enthüllt kommen die
halt und das ist ein bisschen komisch
dass die dann keine angst vor wasser
haben finde ich ein bisschen doof
irgendwie ein bisschen nicht nachgedacht
in der tribüne oder so allerdings ist
das fällt jetzt konfekt nummer zwei und
nummer zwei wurde nämlich zugesendet von
let's play hd und zwar habe ich hier
schon fünf rüstung stein und ich habe
fünf verschiedene schwerter inventar ist
es ja so wenn ich mit dem schwert hier
worauf schlag oder so auf dem boden also
im creative mode und game hotkey game zu
null geht das natürlich nicht
dann kann mit den schwertern demnächst
kaputt machen weil die schwerter dafür
ausgelegt sind im game auch dass man
damit tiere töten kann ohne dabei die
komplette welt kaputt zu schlagen habe
ich ja schon mal gezeigt allerdings kann
man damit mit den scheren kann man halt
einen blog so mehr oder weniger ich
glaube es ist sogar nur dieser eine blog
kann man diesen einen blog kaputt machen
und zwar geht das mit einem eisen
schwert mit einem holzschwert mit einem
stein steht einem diamant und mit einem
gold wert und zwar ist das der rüstung
ständer
lockt man kann nur diesen rüstung
ständer wenn ich falsch liege berichtigt
mich aber letztlich hat er das auch
geschrieben dass man nur den rüstungs
ständer mit einem schwert kaputt machen
kann und ich würde sagen dass war feck
nummer zwei und jetzt kommt carlo
kleider knubbelnase hallo großer knüppel
haase
der dritte weg wurde mir zugesandt von
chan und zwar hat spanien selber schon
mal in seiner folge vorgestellt hat er
geschrieben per mail allerdings meinte
er dass ich das ganze einfach auch mal
cool vorstellen soll weil das noch nicht
so viele kennen und viele sich da also
kleiner knubbelnase deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht okay ich stelle einfach mal
vorbei so richtig cool effect ist wir
kennen das ganze natürlich wenn ich im
creative bin und ich sehe hier einen
block dann kann ich da einfach mit der
mittleren maustaste drückt und ich habe
den bock inventar wenn ich eine kiste
allerdings nehme und kann ich natürlich
auch mittlere maustaste drücken habe ich
hier diese kiste möchte jetzt allerdings
entsetzt ist halt natürlich nichts drin
das gleiche ist allerdings wenn ich hier
einfach mal in meiner kiste lege ich
zwei kisten reihen 64 diamanten und 6
fahren jetzt ist das alles hier drin und
normalerweise wenn ich jetzt mittlere
maustaste mache bekomme ich hier so eine
kiste und da ist nix drin
wenn ich allerdings so inventars
komplett leer mit ihr seht wenn ich
jetzt allerdings mal so mache habe ich
auch die kirche habe ich auch mit
loslassen
da habe ich die sachen da drin und das
ist wenn man steuerung dabei drückt das
ist ein extrem cool affekt den ich
selbst nicht wusste der mir glaube ich
noch kein mal zu gesendet wurde ihr seht
im inventar truhe truhe die stecken sich
dann allerdings nicht decken sich dann
nur die tun
die lehrer sind also hier diese beiden
habe ich jetzt immerhin gesetzt
ordnung der ist dement folge dessen
kleine ahnung was ich die widerlager was
drin
also wenn ihr in einer truhe ein paar
sachen ab dann macht einfach steuerung
und mittlere maustaste und dann bekommt
ihr die tour mitsamt der sachen und das
extrem cool danke an dicht schaden dass
das vorstellen durfte der nächste feld
wurde mir zugesendet von morton und zwar
meint morton dass man einen schneemann
auch waagerecht bauen kann also ich
mache jetzt mal so sagte habe ich ja
hier platte da jetzt habe ich in
schneemann ist das einfach gestorben
weil es hier so heißt hier kein problem
gar keine sache für mich mache ihr leben
hier so dessen alter wo ist es denn
nicht zu heiss kollege wenn wir jetzt
hier auch nicht leben kann sondern
häufig aber so jetzt habe ich auf jeden
fall ein schneemann das ist das rezept
ganz normal für ein schneemann
man kann allerdings auch so machen ich
kann einfach so und zack und man kann
nicht ein schneeball alten schneeballen
schneemann auch waagerecht bauen es geht
aber irgendwie nicht wenn ich irgendwie
so machen wenn ich den so hinlege
sondern ich musste ihn schon in diese
richtung machen und das ist halt das
einzige wie man auch noch ein schlimmer
machen kann das auf jeden fall ganz
witzig zu wissen und ja dann kann dich
morgen ihr fünfter wurde mir zugesandt
von sarah und zwar mein savio bau doch
mal das hier so alles auf ich hab das
jetzt immer so gemacht mit kumpels doch
einfach ihr wasser hin hier zwei
eisengitter vor dieser op die kann ja
effekte mama sieht eigentlich sogar
schön aus wenn das hier am rand ist und
zwar ich laufe jetzt einfach dahin
nämlich ich laufe einfach nur ich
springe nicht ich laufe einfach nur wenn
ich hier bin fange ich automatisch an zu
hüpfen
ich weiß nicht woran das liegt eventuell
dass das wasser darauf breit und hier
noch so ein bisschen wasser hoch sondern
hüfte irgendwie automatisch keinen plan
genau wie das ganze funktioniert also
ich bin nicht am hüpfen ich weiß nicht
wie ich euch zeigen soll dass sie nicht
am hüpfen bin aber eher deswegen test
ist einfach selbst zeigt euch hier so
wird das ganze gebäude können es einfach
nachbauen
da fängt man irgendwie automatisch an zu
hüpfen ich weiß nicht woran es liegt
sarah weiß auch nicht woran es liegt
wir wissen alle nicht wenn kommentare
das alle fünf effekt normalerweise ist
das video schon vorbei allerdings hat
mir noch eine person einen total krassen
fag zugesendet und zwar meinke place der
hut einer excel sieht aus wie scheiß
ko-runde diesem extrem krassen und total
interessanten sechs effekt würde ich
sagen beenden bildern auf diese frei
tägige effects folge die nächste folge
kommt am dienstag dann allerdings immer
noch ohne geheimnisvolles geräusch weil
ich die meisten leute sind echt dagegen
und ich
einfach sagen ich komplett neue softbox
ich kaufe meine neue als tastatur ich
momentan zu essen
ich kümmere mich jetzt mal ein bisschen
und mich okay gut